i'm jada i go here
so
one thing that i've heard of that i
i've not heard any conservative or
liberal people saying
is that while there's a
increase in
like transgender woman to men that's
going on there's also an increase in
women being diagnosed with autism in
their teens and twenties i don't know if
you've heard anything about that or
about any studies that might relate
having gender dysphoria with autism and
maybe if it's a symptom of that nobody's
talking about
i have i was reading one of these today
actually that a young gal i forget her
name
was uncomfortable in her body as all as
all teenagers are
it happened to you as well wow could you
tell but before i tell you about some
our article i read on the internet what
happened i was told to keep it brief but
i guess i'll tell you oh yeah yes
keep it long keep it lengthy i want to
hear the story
as a kid i
i didn't
i i liked both girl and boy things as a
kid which that's what a lot of people go
through and then as soon as i hit
puberty it's like
i could not deal with the changes in my
body and i didn't really have a word for
it yet as transgenderism but like
i would bind my chest in secret i would
make my clothes to where like it would
hide my hips
and
you know i had my church and my family
who was like
they reaffirmed me that i was a girl
which i'm very thankful for because at
that point i definitely wanted to go on
hormones as soon as i could and if i was
still it with the influence of the
left and the lgbt
like i would have gone on hormones and i
would have de-transitioned because
it was a symptom of my autism that i got
diagnosed with at 20 and it wasn't like
actual gender dysphoria
i've heard a number of stories i told
you i was reading one of these today
abigail schreier has written a book
about it called irreversible damage
about the regret about these same sorts
of issues that you're talking about
which is good and the media completely
shut it out you are not allowed to tell
that story the young woman i spoke to
just the other day helena kirschner she
is not allowed to tell her story about
coming to realize no i'm not i'm not
actually a man i realize this isn't
working you were so fortunate you were
so fortunate
that your family and your community
were saying
you were so fortunate that your family
and community were sane and did not
indulge this delusion and the scariest
part the scariest part is that a lot of
the families who will indulge
this kind of transgender mania that
could be caused by any other number of
conditions notably autism though you're
right that is cropping up quite a lot
a lot of these families just want to do
what's best for their kid and they're
being told by these sickos on television
and in the universities and in the
political apparatus that the only way to
treat your kid is to lop off their
genitals and inject them with cross-sex
hormones absolute irreversible damage
that would have caused frankly and as
you're describing in your case greater
regret than you were and stress and
anxiety than you were experiencing even
in the moment that's incredibly i'm so
glad that you were able to come through
that and have a a real medical diagnosis
in the end that did not result in you
mutilating yourself
it's amazing
shout out to my mom in my catholic
church i'm sorry i say it one more time
shout out to my mom in my catholic
church yeah good job good job mom good
job church and really great stuff thank
you thank you for telling that story
wow